hello everybody happy Tuesday I'm John
Luke and I'm joined once again by Ben
Janko let's do it it we're doing cloud
boy whoa we're doing Cobb punk this is a
brand new game that came out last week
right yeah it's I think it was last week
like the 24th or something heck it's not
even them yeah this is a cloud Punk
we're gonna check it out from what from
from from Cloud Strife to cloud Punk no
matter of weeks
it's it's great you know what it is I
were to start over I didn't actually I
just like turn the game on to make sure
it was a video game before starting
definitely a good thing to do yeah so I
know a little bit about this from from
pax I got to see it there last year
you're basically like a delivery driver
in a but cyber put cyberpunk sorry burp
um there's so many we could have done so
many like what if we put could have put
him like I'm the title card pointing at
the game very chilled window cleaner
says can't wait for the 25 minutes of
livestream start our starting sign to be
over good news for you it's already over
it's already over and you're not you're
here
he was in the big sector six crash last
week sector six crash no plate fell down
too soon oh I got caught up in trying to
listen to what these people say oh man a
butcher people got retired and cuz
sector six collapse country roads take
me home do they do it on purpose
alright give me a direction name where
am I going here we go
this game looks really good like gotten
through what I'm watching I'm into it is
this on pc yes yes it is in fact on PC
banquettes says now why can't we get a
cruising skies like game redeliver
stuffs Gaiden yeah
I think about crimson skies every other
day I missed that game and I wish that
we could get I don't know maybe like
even with the backwards compatibility
online working for that again yeah if
they could just add online that'd be
pretty cool cuz that was a big part of
that game also I don't know if anyone's
looked at the cutscenes from crimson
skies in a while but they look like
something on a second
yeah crimson sky that has that uh that
real Rocketeer vibe yeah I love me some
Rocketeer yeah right
Brandon calls out my lack of face cam
its laundry day and I look like ha
garbage just so I don't want to like I
want to make you guys have to look at
them
I guess oh wait I should park over here
at the parking spot
but uh I'll paint a picture with my
words in case you you want to know I'm
wearing a an old t-shirt and a headband
to keep my hair out of my head because I
haven't are out of my face because I
haven't had a chance to get my hair cut
you'll never see this is going to the
marrow where's that pretty low in the
city superstructure I'll give you a
weight point on your help you find it be
careful down there it's busy so where to
go okay nailing it do you you're
starting off that's fine you know you
seem like a nice kid 14 FC I don't know
it sounds like it I'll try what's in the
package two rules kid don't miss a
delivery don't ask what's in the package
oh that's why all these people in the
last tonight is this illegal are we
doing illegal deliveries I think so the
the steam page described as shady shady
dealings oh very kind of dealings Oh
I might have accidentally okay I think I
maybe went to a different part of the
town but I wasn't supposed to
so you're just more you're getting a
feel for it no no hey Ritchie good to
see you avatars is true avatars are
pretty pretty great I got that that face
rig program I shouldn't mess with that
one day and just surprise everyone
sorry just making a kind of joke go
ahead control both characters it's been
really tutorial II but I like how
throwing in a little bit of flavor a
little bit spice in there yeah hey kill
the maro
let's reveille they said I need to go
miss that I guess see is there fuel in
this game I don't know if they're the
end like a fuel thing to work that's
like but I feel like if you've any sir I
think there is if you look next to my
money there seems to be a fuel meter so
you can't have like a good delivery game
without having to worry about your fuel
the city in the city anyone know the
Xbox version performs I this is all I've
seen really is from the Steam version I
can't I can't help you unfortunately
stops just flying straight up to the
spire to write aimless repetitive
how do you do deliveries it's in the
journey though what happens on your way
to do those deliveries that could
probably what I park so think maybe the
the expectation of having it be
repetitive might be part like the the
kind of disarming part of it and then uh
listen you're gonna be like oh no the
deals gone bad the cops are after you
quick escape
it was I Trixie deal would you like to
appear on my food review channel it's on
all the Nets we're looking for people to
react to different stimuli can you
pretend to be sick on cam what no what
would you pretend to be really annoyed
our viewers love that okay ting
Oh crazy sexy had no fuel me over dev
o'clock you know the clock is kind of
like an artificial fuel meter but I mean
I love Crazy Taxi so much
you do love Crazy Taxi could do like
it's a really weird thing what you want
I got I got your brain good candy bar
soda can oh my candy bar
delicious thanks much sweet it says
Paris asks what game is this and
Zachary's got you back
it is cloud punk a cyberpunk delivery
game it's my parents they died you know
poor only knows what caused the crash
I'm sure they saved their whole life
limbs but my neighbor said they probably
leave me pressed gold that way you don't
pay so much city tax on the transfers
can I take that now sure here you go
who is Cora it's just an expression
you want to see what's inside look at it
yes just say this is how you get wrapped
up in bad stuff you think I can finally
get the eye surgery I need two augments
no expense spared no expense spared
hardly read the holocrons these days
it's all just a blur
let's see just to rip here and no what
is it gold
Randall is asking if you turn the game
volume a little bit I'm gonna be talking
over them I'm a fool r7 ICBM and Sputnik
the NASA shuttles the UN interplanetary
101 why did they send these it must be
some kind of code there's a note right
yeah let's see dear Erwin we know these
toys were important to you at one time
we need to sell the apartment but your
father has a scheme it seems risky but
if all goes well this will arrive just
before we land at the colonies we're
going to the stars just like we always
dreamed I know it's hard out there but
if we keep our heads down and we can
start sending you money for the
operations more than enough money just
hold on honey that's the press thing to
be okay I was gonna say shooter got
wrapped up with all the story they
stopped talking yeah yeah I guess so
man they really hitting you with the
hard and hard stuff up front yeah I'm I
don't investigate figuring out what's
going on here this is a lot here
like your comments are you oh I
appreciate that you said that you like
the comments here that doesn't happen
very often
try to straddle the game what made you
want to come slumming with us in the
follows it's the biggest city in the
world I wanted to make an impression
it's not easy to break out in the
mollusk in making it here is like trying
to paint on the surface of a river the
current of people and ideas and the
crowds they didn't wash everything away
I'll make it sure you will kid just try
making it through tonight first we need
you to they keep saying in the world
yeah what's the job same as always take
a package from A to B without too many
questions hear me out
B as a bad house it's just five nights
at Freddy's but you're in a car don't
try to make it through the night the
merchants are as far from the clouds
clear it's not clickbait at all this is
a Simon pump delivery my way yeah you
can see it with your eyes
yeah what's I mean it'd be clickbait if
we're like cyberpunk 2077 what taxis
Keanu Reeves but you're a woman and you
drive a car what is uncool if you're
unaware is just a game that's coming out
it's an aesthetic it's a way of life one
thing I wish that this had is in between
the missions you have to wait for them
to finish talking before they tell you
where to go next
I kind of wish they would just update
yeah why don't you do like sickening
that works too then the transfer cost to
unlock the automata is big cyberpunk
2077 mini-game direct transfer please
insert storage media transfer in process
personality chemists will be activated
and approximate ominous my favorite
character yes deactivating please enjoy
your new automata good day mr. rania oh
they'll do I like that you can like
actually bump into stuff like that cuz I
keep forgetting I need to feel like
sometimes feel like sometimes and stuff
like this still put like invisible walls
also like this hmm okay
hold on let's get some food oh heck yeah
if there's a dealer there you just
passed up the dealer I'm gonna get some
vegan ramen though not bad just ramen in
a soda can put the ramen in the soda can
that's so that's a referential I'm sure
you from the east lady you're good
oh no Corp SEC got it ooh stimulants and
in juice juice I guess Thanks
hey that's the juice you folks from the
East are good with me it's adjacent to
the sauce but it's the juice instead
you the delivery driver yes I'm from
cloud Punk let's name the game all right
that's the name of the game don't ask me
about it and don't be late and before
you ask yes it's supposed to smell like
that okay thanks
is this real meat what did I just say
yeah Wow already messing up I love it
that's this is why people don't make it
through the night they end up asking all
these questions they buy all this juice
from the dealer get all spice what's
giving you the most trouble the traffic
yeah and how fast everyone drives they
all know exactly where they're going
you'll be that fast once you get your
bearings faster even just remember the
highways Channel and it does air he
knows I'm talking about we got all the
credits
we got the we got a double title drop
it's pretty simple when you're on the
highways it's like the road is moving
under you oh I see you mean fastest use
the high get as close to your
destination as you can
and then cut off when you're close I can
only Park in the base right yeah that's
right
Papa's aren't meant to touch the ground
the repulsors on the parking bees keep
the undercarriage a few centimeters off
the ground it's not just it I feel bad
like I'd have to stop if I want to
listen to the conversation if they
really should have like like you know
how got a war has like anything would
pick up stories or conversations that
take him back to the boat or yeah maybe
like as I was saying like from GTA did
it to the wheels of commerce on ps4 no
this is on pc i don't know if it's on
other consoles i should look it might be
xbox as well
yeah let me double check just so I can
wedge
you see
oh it's on PlayStation 4 switch Xbox
around windows so some everything about
what you're watching is PC
[Music]
the gears tactics a video yesterday
anyone play Gears of War again I was
thinking about that cuz I technically
still haven't finished four we haven't
finished five I should go back and do
those at some point yeah I played some
tactics this morning that's a good time
I mean I also spent $200 on games this
morning like an idiot oh I bought Sakura
wars
oh right which was a cool ad right off
of the bat and then remnant was on sale
for the first time in like forever so I
finally picked that up with the new
expansion there were some other things
along the way some like Final Fantasy's
that I might hit up at some point cuz
I'm still in that that JRPG hole and I
can't get out of I can't escape the JRPG
hold this looks stunning what a
beautiful game thank you for this hey
happy to help show you guys some cool
things that are out we think might be
worth your time alright no one look I'm
typing in my pin code I'm not looking
you're saying it out loud well maybe I
don't actually know it uh do you have
like an inventory you could pull up that
might have looking like something you
could look at inventory punch-card no I
just found on the ground oh dang scheme
has a good story and it's just a
beautiful game it's what it looks like
ah I forgot to talk well we were talking
to one of the characters and I was like
oh no it only really happens when I'm
streaming naka soda beer that's my
employer give it to me this instant a
street rat as this bean temple Wow what
i justed most drivers I didn't read the
script it's orange mm-hmm
the smell makes them curious what's in
the package
dinner meat watch me what a strange
question good day
Brandon says that they beat river city
girls this morning and they really liked
it yeah thank you I'm very glad that you
you had a good time with it it's it's a
good time I need to go back and do it
again because they didn't update the
changes and I fell for you today I want
to see that also I just won't play that
game again
you got Streets of Rage coming up this
week thanks so I'll be fun you want to
keep the beat him ups going is this game
online this game is not online it's a
single-player story of you guys so much
please keep the good work out that you
do our best
thank you just for you to wipe your
record so we need them to hold a clean
file on you they won't recognize me
sending you a nav point now when's the
next animal crossing stream and can I
join you it it's a good questions
business should hit Animal Crossing up
again to some point but we'll let you
know for sure yeah maybe maybe next time
there's another big update that make
sense to do
gun two versus heck yeah let's get on
some of those Gundam games only if I get
to be big Zam all the time the best
Kondo
oshri to reach for is also a game past
games shoot it is that game that's Bob
Jones bringing in the good [ __ ] there's
been a lot of really good beat-em-ups
voluntary contribution I wish people
would just call them bribes what's that
nothing officer here's my details okay I
just have to create a new record for you
and then hold please I'm getting a
message in my earpiece
yes agent Rio no sir
her name is Rani a cloud Punk I don't
think so sir yes sir I'll ask her yes
sir
I'll tell you if I think she's lying
ma'am oh you know or have you at any
time been a part of the illicit delivery
service known as Chloe never heard of
them smooth she said she's never heard
of them
I believe her sir okay well you're a
sucker
got'em yes yep okay then I'll do that
sir yes sir okay miss you can go your
details have been updated when I scanned
your ID our server said you're a
musician from the Eastern Peninsula play
me a song if this if this were Final
Fantasy 7 you would have had to play the
piano or something I want that I want
that so bad
flying discs look good this came just to
the cyberpunk aesthetic is really cool
and they're just just neon bright lights
everywhere and I like it a lot I'm have
to pick up this game after we're done
with the stream because I didn't expect
to be using do it as I was in here I am
very cyberpunk so focused on phone away
from me too busy shopping and using
makeup women in their makeup in their
shopping I don't think you want me on
your show and I sure don't want to be on
it either let's try to talk to someone
better bro brothers we got to find the
real voice of the people we're all
brothers he seems to be looking at you
he seems like a real man this is a
perfect time to remind you guys if you
enjoy watching please subscribe to the
cheap
Ordo it's not you don't have to if you
don't want to but it is the best way to
know whatever shouldn't come up with a
nickname for all of our audience
memories we should but it all never be
as impactful as bro brothers now really
well unfortunately I can't find this an
xbox I have no idea how to find it on
other systems other than maybe do like a
search or check out new releases in the
store it might be in the game past
section - sorry Punk will be out for
another 57 years yeah that's that's fair
I mean I'm really excited to see what
that's going on terrible plug yeah I
know Bob my heart wasn't in it I felt
bad because the timing was actually bad
I don't want to jump off of the boat the
bro brothers boosting they just cross
promoted on our stream how dare they
can't believe it
the game spotters spot all the content
when it comes out it's true so later
this year that would explain it
so we might just have access to it on
the PC earlier saying this is a heads up
then though keep an eye out for it what
what what feels strange
use your dog my vehicles automata slot
oh oh sorry kamas this is all I can
afford right now do we just put did she
hook her dog's personality in her car
you were the best kamas I am Czestochowa
now not as good oh I know we'll get you
a new body I promise I'll take a while I
have a new job you don't play music
anymore
I like music just when I thought I was
like I cool I mean I'm this like makes
me I had to move us to new vollis oh no
we hate the city we did maybe it's not
so bad now I'm doing deliveries we are
doing deliveries I am helping Oh
oh ye is helping oh good boy I will help
I feel not so good though I am sleepy
now you're taking nap you deserve it in
the car it's pretty limited and the
hardware runs at a lower clock cycle so
you might need to take it easy for a
while don't understand I was gonna say
that dog is not gonna get it are
multithreaded but that's not supported
with the hardware we have
that means it might take longer to
figure things out but you'll get there
I'm sleepy okay rest for now Camus I'll
bring you online soon and Camus I missed
you too oh okay
games cute wait is is Camus one of the
bro brothers
cuz the bro brother call is the woof
woof I would assume nod but that would
be quite a twist residential zone I'm
sending in that point now okay on my way
wait 14 FC is there a problem no never
mind
good luck okay
man hey I just was expecting to get
honor to do like a live stream today it
just seemed like a game read Rove around
and it expects it I'm invested I'm
bought it I bought the game I've done it
the dog sent me over the edge
the dog has definitely sold me on this
she had all that real estate because I
was too scared to come on now you're
good nope
oh well
I was yawning at this time of the day it
is that like two o'clock into three
o'clock like down turning in the middle
of the afternoon
yeah I just had lunch it's hitting you
you're like oh this this is closing time
this is the done time to it yep that's
exactly it Zach I was about to say
that's a whole $20 I bought the
soundtrack version too cuz I wanted to
give them a little extra yeah also you
know cyberpunk soundtracks are always
permanent so yeah this gives many
music's real good Philip in was a cat
person I like dogs and cats I think I
like dogs just a little bit more
admittedly but I do love my cats um yeah
they're not they're not mine they're my
roommates but you know
control I'm at the destination and no
one is here control chemists are you
awake Lois in 30 minutes there's enough
Bob wake excited Oh what to help can you
scan the area local scan look for ID
chips on possible delivery containers I
don't know how wait I know how what is
box boxes for spies
no what is that box it's right there
okay I see it I guess that's the package
then why is no one here I have bad
feelings me to canvas
I wish I could voice-acted dog in a
cyberpunk video game
is a sense I didn't expect to stay today
at all did you guys review this game we
didn't we don't we don't do the game
reviews it is being reviewed though I
believe I think it's in the process of
it
on the way okay we don't know where to
go hearing noise what noise chemists
from the package tell God loves you all
those tic TOCs I still have bad feelings
one second chemists control come in
control this is drawing 14 FC come in
this is important driver 14 FC this is
control please deliver your current
package with urgency control why is this
package ticking oh man we're yeah
committing acts of terrorism there I am
nervous
oh I am nervous because you are nervous
maybe we can throw away the tick tock
tick tock tick tock tick tock tick tock
the toggles tick-tock the trash chute in
Section 8 B Lancaster will mister
control be mad yes but I get a bad
feeling - countess I think what do you
think I want to help but don't know what
to do should we should we deliver it or
should we throw it away I just have to
make a call on this one
oh I see tried delivery oh I feel like
like it - where we're gonna blow no
actually no dome I think we should it's
watching what if it's missing other
expectations load it makes us think it's
a bomb when it's actually just alarm
this is a test this is a test to prove
that you're down to do the deliveries
for his people and no one's actually
gonna get hurt get into the cyberpunk
frame of mind
all right let's blitz let's deliver it I
want to see what happens Captain Ahab is
reading from my script right now and
putting it to the chat it's a bunch of
Oz people in the chat are also saying
deliver alright we'll see what happens
I'm gonna feel like a real Punk if uh if
it ends up being bad a real cyber Punk a
real cloud Punk a real cloud Punk oh are
you already there all right mr. Kim so I
keep wanting to say kamu instead of
Camus I guess it was nothing we did our
job chemists we shouldn't ask so many
questions I am Not sure you want to say
something if it is okay sure is this a
job good it pays good are we doing good
things no more questions please
Kenneth is it dog the Mariinsky the
times our moral compass it's gonna mess
me up
I hope not ready
damn on our first night - that was
delivering a bomb
anyway bad ending confirms no canvas
won't like that
this is control is there anything you
want to tell me about that last job no
nothing I'm just glad it went okay for
your next delivery please proceed to the
following nav point to collect a package
at Life Corp industries you'll need to
find a way up to the roof of the
building our client didn't leave us an
access code but that's you're a smart
kid that's exactly what I was guessing
was gonna happen bang cat was like as
soon as you said guess it was nothing it
was just gonna go off or something
that's what I thought I was I was kind
of waiting oh yeah that's the other
thing too the dog isn't a real dog it's
an AI dog inside of her her vehicle I'm
confused if it was she said we'll get
you a new body I wonder it has it always
been an AI dog or was it once a real dog
whose brain has been digitized maybe it
was like one of those like one of those
robot pet dogs had is like a kid that
would like do flips and the broke so she
had to upload its consciousness to the
neural network to the cloud
I'm making making up backs are easier
maybe my theory is that it was a real
dog at one point I kind of hope it was a
real dog play monster hunter a world
ice-born after this I could get back at
lost on her at some point yeah they've
been adding stuff to solve very
high-level things you'll find the
package on the roof through the hotel
entry to your right the access code is
b96 5e and don't talk to the package
don't what what you'll see what I mean
it won't shut up it's going to Avalon
Heights they're expecting you
okay okay
is there different whether most of time
in cyberpunk it's got to be sort of
rainy just so you can always have the
lights reflecting off of things I heard
an explosion you must die it was an
explosion control was it at the Metro
hub it was in the bay in the delivery
Bay oh yeah I control
did I just unrelated what your delivery
was unrelated to the explosion I don't
believe it's that bad lying very bad at
why the bonus payment being given more
money control 14f see we are not
authorized to discuss previous jobs
that's in the rules
Wow they were guidelines not rules
please complete your outstanding
contract and life Corp industries
control out control control chemists are
you on comm what happened I am nervous
that was a big boom my windows got shaky
Oh do that you did sound just like Vega
from Jim eternal okay
that uh that man you picked up the stuff
war
all right
you didn't deliver the package I wonder
if your car would have gone boom yeah
I'm curious what would have happened if
you'd chose to not deliver well you
would have dropped it up somewhere else
yeah like would we even drop it like you
were gonna drop it off in like a garbage
chute I don't know if you can just hold
on to it and you'll fight blow up or
something like that maybe it wasn't a
timer on it though
hello can you hear me with that boxes
talking I can hear you box Oh No how are
you today
Camus we're not supposed to talk to the
box I completely understand
are you an Android to chemists
fine you can answer him Camus I am an
automaton I am a dog or a car I am a dog
car
oh man not a box William but what are
you I was a sous chef in China
that makes me sad how come
because I won't be able to talk to
little people like you anymore
that won't be a shame Avalon hides my
god wait what will you do up there yeah
there's a lot of fifth element kind of
feel going I'm sure humming near dark I
know it does continue the conversation
okay I'm ready to have this guy's dreams
be crushed he's not going someplace good
none taken other gun chases or battles
not yet know that I will be rich
I might even be an organizer for charity
dinners you won't be invited of course
but I would talk about you thanks and
I've only been a driver for a little
while I was a musician
perhaps I shall be a musician of course
I would be too rich and too busy to
learn to play but kind of all that goes
William yep definitely big same dude
uh-huh rania lost her home and we were
evicted box I mean William we had to
move to the city
why dead corpse oh yes they can't be
very unpleasant
I have heard she had to sell my body for
money to a soul no with which I am
familiar i sold my body also you see
ship's android body is worth a lot these
days i was the only part of me worth
anything
now i'm just a head and a dream can we
open the box young boy i want to see the
head no we're not allowed to open the
packages we're not supposed to speak to
them either i am sad
he'll get over it same canvas what will
your new body be like oh let's guess
accent me something good i love it they
treated my old body yeah right apartment
in all my savings for this place in the
spire surely they have the best android
frames there too yeah this guy's not
gonna it's not gonna end well
no after we just blow up the metro
station i have a bad feeling about
literally anything else we're doing
going forward I agree
I'm going the right way
a Fifth Element racing game I can't say
that I do remember that sounds like a
fun time I mean the fun I guess within a
reason because apparently it was a
difficult game from what you're saying
right area
hope it's a dream right
hello we have a delivery his name is
what gets so many subs for all those
unboxing videos Reginald Barclay squad
yeah senior senior we're vacuum cleaner
no and the refuse disposal officer with
cleaning functions the senior refuse
disposal officer and this is our new
recruit no no he's a janitor will be
mounted his dreams swimming unit 3000
and you will be working on the three
thousand two hundred and eighty seventh
floor of avalon heights as the junior
apprentice unit Sarge hey sorry
Oh what I am to be the junior apprentice
please pass me over to mr. Buckley I'm
keen to get we can no longer be friends
right I like you and your pet human but
it just wouldn't be the done thing to be
seen with you oh I understand
I am happy for you goodbye man he is
enjoying it and you know what cool
yeah if he seems happy that's way I
liked a speed booster
I appreciate the the camera shifting
like that
over the place
it's a good soon we got flute I've had
that yet sir it sir old music
instruments hmm wondering if I have to
apply the speed booster it's just
automatic
do you miss William I do not okay
me neither what do you want to work for
the UPS place every Punk at the same
time that's very fair we have a home
is it big does it have a garden do I
have my own room
sorry chemists it's not really a home
it's just a place where we can stay for
a while and it's all I can cloud Punk's
salary sleeping on my bed behind the
house maybe we can go somewhere nicer as
cloud punk pays us lots chemist life is
going to be hard here in Navarre
you need to prepare yourself for that
even this place might be too expensive
we can't afford to mess up got it dang
that night and we could be evicted we're
not even in a good spot I understand and
we're delivering don't so don't get
excited about this new place it's but
you got the bonus for doing it yeah we
did get the bonus Hey okay I understand
I am still excited
you who do I gotta talk to about voicing
a cyberpunk dog I'm gonna put the call I
got to make some tweets I gotta have my
people talk to some other people
there's a lot of good opportunities fat
you know yeah right
cyber Street and maybe maybe alter
altered carbon season three there you go
there's a robot dog in metal gear at one
point that was neat mm-hmm
I'm sure LaRon they're good they're good
opportunities there somewhere I just you
know I can't think of
you're all right back to our apartment
gamer's awesome but the gameplay Oh God
yeah that's that's fair
[Music]
I really just like the look and sound of
everything while you're driving around
is really good
depending on how how long this is I
might might do this before I jump into
sucker wars for smooch out in those
giant mech robots how long that game
probably like 40 hours I'm guessing
we've got I got some cool cool things
coming through apparently shame thinks
or feels that canvases that [ __ ] the
best talking companion that has ever
been in games wow such fun relief in a
pretty serious game could also be
because they're biased in love dogs
I accept that bias that's a good biased
yeah I agree
and you know what I could I could see
them being one of the best companions
easily started gasps good time seen oh
it's this guy this guy again sunglasses
are a I feel like if we're struggling we
probably shouldn't be out buying
designer purses yeah maybe
do I know you are you really struggling
if you look like you're not struggling
what that's a good point
if I knew you I might not know it's all
about facades why are you hanging
outside my apartment are you with the
debt Corp for Corp SEC are you spying on
me I am your neighbor shouldn't you be
in your apartment then hey Ethan how's
it going welcome what do you want I want
to know if I know you if we used to know
each other if we were friends no I just
moved in I've never met you before
are you okay no android' right so did
you have a firmware upgrade that went
wrong or something I hear those can
cause androids to lose their memories I
think no do you remember my friend dr.
adzick
we live next door no I told you I just
moved in she is missing I am alone look
I'm really busy I just missing doctor I
don't want money why would you say that
I didn't ask you for money I'm sorry I
just don't know if I'm the best person
to help you I don't know anyone else
there's some homeless shelters for
androids downtown I have a home nothing
sounds less appealing than a homeless
shelter for an Android I think it is for
me that's it just a card yes I need it
it is how I will start to come back to
me okay
find a punch card in your apartment
isn't is that the punch card you have in
your inventory already here a different
one oh that's gotta be it right there
you're authorized to access the systems
in here I am here it is amazing there's
a table and a balcony and the roof
perfectly fits on top of the walls yeah
it's alright I guess it's a pretty nice
apartment I'm gonna be honest thank you
if kuma says we should play more
fighting games against each other I
agree there are rats
I detect almost 50 within the property
oh never mention rats again okay
there are also a number of rare breeds
of some spider
No thank you not good come on we should
get back to work
if I get a bonus tonight maybe I can buy
a picture or a mirror or something you
did get a bonus see what you get
whoo I did get a lamp a pizza
subscription get a random pizza daily
for one month play that retro game
consoles cat - a dog house we have to
get a square you can access oh yeah this
is all for him
no idea kid this one's gonna be tricky
but I think you can do it
the club's picky about who gets in
fortunately for us it's tricky to rock a
rhyme that's right on time
he's the owner of the club been washing
it's out now on pcs but it's coming out
later on in the year for consoles and
it's unlike every nicely doghouse
expecting me we have a fridge sure I'm
just letting you know you might come up
against some resistance these are
powerful people so watch what you say
yeah be nice to see what you are come
back good point another Goku hot on the
way sad that the guilty your strive beta
times didn't line up with our stream
yeah sacrifice for some reason to say it
is Camus in this game but that's not
that's not what that word contact with
drivers there's something in the air
tonight be careful hold on past
infractions are forgiven understood
understood
oh yeah fractions we did pretty good
though
and maybe that was if we need frictions
well maybe if we did a blow up that not
delivery not deliver that bomb thank you
what is it pink yeah it also brings up
another good point
hard times barely any money but that
apartment is huge that's what I was
saying like that's a really nice
apartment she's like god it's a shitty
apartment what does a huge apartment
maybe my cyber folks tigress maybe my
cloud pungesti maybe yeah but this card
I know this is just the first of many
where are the rest you don't want me to
check with all our neighbors do you the
rest were with doctors Sh
they are scattered okay so where all
these punch turns I'm scared
you mean last month the 1875 B shuttle
for Phobos took off from Terminal B
while the launch Bay Doral still chased
one of the series of systemic failures
that took place across a range of new
vollis's safety protocol algorithms the
explosion caught over 100 vehicles in
the blast radius including doctor
diseases Hova so she's I'm sorry you did
not know her but thank you she was your
flatmate we were best friends
we came to new vollis together we met at
the periphery she was the last doctor to
leave I was the last surgeon so you are
dr. Evelyn although I was conferred the
title none of the humans used it but if
you were operating and saving lives you
were a doctor if no one calls you a
doctor or treats you like one you are
not a doctor damn still you were saving
lives and please do not tell me how to
label myself sorry
so the periphery I hear it was pretty
dangerous out there it was but no vollis
is dangerous - is it better here in the
city I saw - yes having a hard time with
the rain it seems friends I have not
found those things here yet will you set
up practice here in Davos I don't know
dr. Zee's each had a plan for us but it
is no longer in my memories I guess I
can look for these pages it sport
Android city so it would help me a great
deal please bring me any you find I will
and if you need it so you have a good
day though thank you yes neighbors keep
those Russian skies safe
all right so we're finding all these
punch cards for her of which we have
full right now we would look in a
thriving cyberpunk civilization it's
poetic topless man on the cover weird
hmm oh geez name in this town Rin oh
heck yeah move in neo don't worry dude
hey yeah I wanna live in neo don't burry
who also has jammed oh yeah beyond Dark
Souls 3 fighting games in Australia heck
yeah
Siberian blizzard you know it man I kind
of miss Polk Street
your betters a good time some spicy wall
checks that's that's fine just got to
make sure the car still works
control
it's gotta go find a way to repair
okay
it looks like it controls just like when
I imagine a hovering car so that bad but
it's the little markings all around we
don't look like undercover Corp SEC what
would undercover Corp SEC look like
chemists I guess maybe like us we have
to act natural not suspicious you know
fly casual it is hard to act not
suspicious when you are worried about
being killed you know talking too much
you're learning fast chemists
alright let's repair this vehicle I know
I spent all my money on the could have
gotten those plasteel bumpers shoot
alright well we'll have to wait until we
get the money for the job I'm just gonna
you're gonna fly really safe I spent all
my money on furniture
I mean sweet jams you get a hot rod
here's hoping
yeah I'm really not regretting getting
the soundtrack version of this game
hey there black labs good to see ya
interesting game I agree
I didn't expect to kind of get caught up
in it as much as I was when I was lucky
I'll be on the stream and hang out but
now now I'm really do it
yeah a bit too tough dog it is it's a
doggy tie that's inside of your car not
your best friends I am smoking a little
bit we'll just have to be careful
yeah I saw him to see that dope yep
careful don't like it
man you are you get close there
sometimes I'm worried
I trust you put up worries basically you
have to protect your car at all costs
because your car is your dog that's true
the random police sirens really help
sell the the cyberpunk feel - they do oh
yeah we got them go nowhere I can follow
you you mean like like us subscribe to
the channel and know whenever we go live
unless you're talking about Twitter coms
that's the whole of the deal
I found an ocarina whoo what it's an
ocarina everyone like it's not as young
guess someone lost it it's dirty dirty
ocarina is my new Final Fantasy 14
character trading card
Gold Series pretty rare it's true if
chemists eyes Tsugaru gotta wipe
everything it's done you hold on there
it is rock stars midnight club it's back
just hiding out inside a cloud poke the
whole time yeah I really love the rain
being everywhere to shine all the neon
lights everywhere it's it's real good
okay I might have parked in the wrong
spot dirty ocarina of grime Oh perfect
ship it
I still listen to that mashup album
ocarina of rhyme it's very good it's a
team teamwork I think that oh you know
what never mind I think I was in the
right spot I just needed to use the the
door I'm silly it's all good
so you're really good at parking that
was real smooth thank you today geez he
got me nothing is a game the game is
great I'm just sleepy big same all the
time always tired never not tired
who are you I'm here to deliver a
package sure you are [ __ ] off look whoa
they're expecting me in the VIP area
upstairs make it worth my while how I
don't have much money I don't want money
get me some juice whoa tramadol dude
it's a good thing we bought that juice
sell them the juice is loose yeah we
have that juice juice go ahead
saying all it took was a charge drugs to
get into the VIP does that say sin wave
in the bag does oh man I'm not the
carmine he used to run my packages he
retired well the new narrative pieces
making deliveries it's a good call bank
hat appreciate though the reminder to to
repair that's right
you bring the packages no questions no
mistakes we'll be friends if you let me
down
probably no whoa look at that money
what's your name rania sure [ __ ] with me
look on your face but those are some
clean hands in the city you've got to
just wash them a little the quarantine
but we still swimming well your hands
are clean the city is real fast
and you got to move with it you make a
million choices a day to survive in
Nevada and some of those choices are
gonna hurt folks oh yeah we'd love a
building think about that yeah not too
long ago actually I think so all right
get going then Anya Cora willing you
might just make it through the night
Quora wasn't as good as avatar that's
the general consensus right uh no it's
not
I like Korra quite a bit though yeah
here it's still very good I I really
really like Korra I think it's a very
good show
but it is more uneven I would I would
argue avatar is flawless is a perfect
ship always I think I think that show
has almost no faults to it whatsoever
Tang core core is a bit more messy I
think it's got some some problems
especially in the in the second season
and elements of the first season Korra
but ooh there's some stuff that's real
strong just an expression that it's real
real good in that show yes so haven't I
bought like a blu-ray set with hundreds
of them on it I need to assess yeah I
highly recommend watching Korra I think
it's very good anyway that was my big
side thing because they're saying
something it sounds like Korra
theology sociology or infrastructure of
city operation it's diagnosed a lot in
text okay that's plenty
damn I can't oh man relevance chemist
should I look it up
wait we have an incoming call get you
there
ready for another job sure thing thank
you this guy what is Cora look the ants
are the blue aliens better when you're
tired
according Carol imagine you last
airbender brought with it that's that's
kind of what I hear people say he's job
with what are delivering to a nun's
thank you sorry I'm sorry I missed that
I wants a drive converter from oh it
doesn't have the same magic it's not
it's not quite there yeah I'd agree I
think it I think it it has its own its
own magic to it in spots it's I think
the worst thing you could do is go into
Cora expecting it to be just like Avatar
you have to kind of come to it on its
own terms
it means something to him won't we get
in trouble
oh my head it's got some beautiful
animation speed processor so that's why
you're struggling take yourself offline
while you do the search I'll be okay
without you for a while you need to swim
you remember how to do that you need to
copy yourself into the other networks
and travel upstream
I remember you're looking for Korra
remember I want old data where did the
name come from that's your focus old
data
why is she really really determined to
figure that out yeah we know our cars
damaged really badly but the money the
money's rough you know yeah where where
this just makes it this is the hard mode
challenge you know you got to make all
the deliveries without blowing your
chart one one life run you know
I'm here to collect a driver converter
Drive converter sure you don't know what
it is do you nope
it regulates the hydraulic output of the
water tanks it wears out fast but
without it
you got no grav lift the Sun comes up
residue from the runoff because we got
no clean water down here no more
only the fancy over cloud homas can run
without a drive converter because they
used pure h2o you're not listening are
you
this guy sounds like he's about to tell
me about like the do this the state
frugal of the the state that I'm moving
in yeah and how it's locally farmed
groaning sources you would definitely
appear on a Florida nostalgic taste of
Tropicana fresh-squeezed orange juice
[Music]
nothing hits quite hard like a capri-sun
oh man I I just put the two together but
I didn't realized that like the whole
Capri Sun like liquid metal thing was
like just taken from Alex Mack oh really
I don't know which way it went like who
did it from what but it was real weird
that like all of that was the same thing
hmm
put that together
I was too busy enjoying my Pacific
coolers okay I'm trying to fuel up here
abort abort if you'll get it out of here
oh we gotta feed the dog that's what it
is
Oh straining your money ya know I had to
sort of make it a choice there Wow when
you good encouragement to not hit
anything maybe we don't need to tell
cloud Punk if we fix the damage quickly
we need one of those repair station
places Amber Alert though why the light
appears on your dashboard that's what
that light means Oh No amber one amber -
amber three and black how do you know
when it's a black alert okay I'm not
really sure I might go right it says the
girl right here this is the objective
because I need to change the light bulb
where is never slow go are you part of
the race I've got a drive converter for
him sweet lovely aim book yeah it's
called cloud Punk it's not I'm steamed
now also hi good to see you DJ sunset
dammit
control are you on the comm what do I do
the race has already started I'm giving
you a nav point seems like he might have
broken down already seriously you have
to complete this job remember what we
told you when you signed up no failures
oh no you have to do a race thing to
like catch up now I'm moving real slow
because I'm uh
I'll try I'm all smoky here remember
straight roads are for fast cars but the
city is for fast drivers
so I'm I'm so worried you're gonna make
me no that was a hit-and-run that guy
did that on purpose
he's you gotta get the license plate
number on him right here get serious
here is about him I found him I did his
team has never slow Joe he's never slow
its parking down there
he still doesn't work worried by this
game now they go wait for the ps4 hey
that's fair okay I think I have to park
down there
I see no how's it going good to see you
so I just realized we're we're coming up
on the the end of the CR it we've got
nine minutes left
we've got we got a saved never slow Joe
though that sign just say thorax
I love it yep perfect
okay that oh here we go
there's a way up
we're on our way I'm really really
digging the soundtrack
don't
or you never slow Joe no I am currently
very slow Joe you got my converter oh
he's got Jukes you can fix it up and
sell it on four good handful of limbs
these converters are worth a lot of
money they sure are
i ôm it so you make sure it gets back to
them safe here without the trade-in
value and that busted converter I
wouldn't be able to afford this repair
my racing days would be over early
retirement I'd go mad I'll get it back
to Emmitt thanks cloud Punk yeah I can't
believe you drive around the city in
that piece of junk
you're Wow kid what do they call you
rania that's no good
my name's no good what do you suggest oh
you can get a racing nickname what do
you think oh I've got a race to win
I hope you've run into him again but
with a better car you get to race him Oh
that'd be pretty good want it
so at least you haven't gotten asked to
do anything kind of to shave you
recently did you hear all of that so we
just have we do we do have an option
here though we can sell it for a lot of
money for you want or give it back to
him we're gonna give it back cuz I like
that guy yeah he was good he gave you a
nickname for free won't you get in
trouble I don't think so
the races are illegal and dangerous Joe
is an old man maybe it would be safer if
he retired if I give this part back to
Emmitt to settle his old debts
he'll keep racing so are you going to
sell the part at some other mechanic man
or take I'll see now they have this
other moral quandary to it yeah the fact
that he should probably retire I mean
it's his choice you know yeah I feel
like I should respect his choice I don't
want to I'll ask room over like that
gotta respect the man yeah unlike how
I've been writing this car oh you mean
your dog my dog car
all right lesson learned if you play
this game don't immediately buy all the
upgrades of the apartment
hey do you buy these it's a drive
converter I don't need it
oh wait oh no no no way I went to the
wrong thing all right
oh no I [ __ ] up you're supposed to pay
off Joe's dead oh no I went to the wrong
objective Joe will stop racing did you
do it to help Joe I did it to help all
three of us welp gotta live with that
choice
but on the plus side my coccyx that's
good
oh no I messed up though [ __ ] oh it was
not paying attention damn
for Team FC we did a status check on
your vehicle performance and it's
running clean as a spire sky yeah that's
right I totally fixed it
look at that I got a bonus because I
kept my car in good condition hold on
I've got something I've got to do
another job
if you're about to give me a headache
worth of data I need a coffee first
let's go get this coffee let's call it
then
let's do it
like I got I got messages popping off I
did I could tell I was gonna say you're
probably get a lot of messages around
this time it's it's always the end of
the day
I really like how each part of the city
feels really different it was gonna say
that they're all pretty distinctive
leave this whole game takes place over
the course of one night
hmm you know you have a coffee after
this or something it sounds like a good
idea and recovered we did it
oh excuse me did you hear that
no they said uh unlicensed jazz is
punishable by death so you know don't
don't don't plenty unlicensed jazz Ben
dude flip in that's my favorite kind of
jazz I guess I got a park
I'll try parking here and see what's up
do we actually wanna call your button
right here before I get to the college
sure yeah let's let's leave the coffee
adventure as a mystery
call teaser yeah we don't want to we
don't want to give away too much all
right I mean yeah this has been cloud
Punk actually wait so I kind of put me
back to the menu or to the other side
punk I like this game quite a bit that's
cool
I'm similar cousin I had to buy it like
20 minutes ago street looks really good
I can't wait to play it yeah I think
this looks really rad I'm really I'm
definitely gonna play more of it I like
all the little story stuff I'm curious
where it's gonna go
I'm also curious if they're gonna add
anything more to it mechanically like
you said maybe like they add races or
anything like that or if this is the
rhythm of the game which is fine I I'm
diggin it so yeah that's been the stream
if you guys like this you should hit
that subscribe button if you already
haven't and check out more of our
streams me and Ben will be back on
Friday for sure yeah to do community
Friday to spend I don't think we have
anything planned yet do we don't think
we do either but we'll figure something
out okay yeah we'll figure out something
for that yeah and yeah otherwise trying
to give this anything else cool you
should look forward to oh we're we're
gonna sell with a potato mode and
hopefully have written for there and a
couple of days so check that out
that should be pretty fun those are
always a fun game today all should be
that event we have going on so we could
talk about that commonly up and yeah you
know yes
forgive me for
remembering the exact name hold on you
think I would know this because I'm I
work here we're gonna play for all which
is our sort of like our big for those
who haven't known we announce our a big
thing called play for all which is like
our our thing that we're gonna be doing
around the ìiî time where we're gonna be
kind of having a bunch of big
announcements from different game
developers I think people like CD
Projekt RED vocalist CD Projekt RED
Bethesda Deep Silver devolver digital
Larian studios along with a couple
others Square Enix Sega that's some
that's some good names in there yeah yes
we might see some cyberpunk 2077
somewhere yeah so it sounds like we all
have some cool announcements happening
on our side but on top of that the whole
thing is gonna be this like multi-week
big why the stream where we're gonna
have a bunch of guests like Danny from
noclip Giant Bomb kind of funny will be
on there I'm sure like just doing stuff
where it's gonna be a marathon so you
know what maybe maybe but then we'll do
some dumb marathon games around that and
the cool thing about it is that we're
not just doing it just to do it we're
actually doing it around a charity event
to donate to Direct Relief which is a
humanitarian aid organization efforts to
help with people who are on the front
lines of coke event team so please go go
to gamespot.com you can find out more
details on that we're also gonna more
details on it in the coming weeks I'm
really excited for that I think it's
super cool that not only are we getting
to do like cool game announcements but
we're actually getting to like you know
put it around this charity event that
can help everyone else for this you know
these trying times yeah cool video games
and charity you can't go wrong with
either oh no you can you really can so
anyway thanks for watching guys and
we'll see ya later